[Musique]
c'est charmant de parler devant des
oiseaux mais qu'il soit vrai ou faux les
oiseaux ne me comprennent pas on fait
des films pour les partager avec les
spectateurs
je me disais ce serait terrible s'ils
n'écoutaient pas ou qui ne regardez pas
le film le cauchemar du cinéaste c'est
qu'ils aient personnes dans la salle
cauchemar
le cauchemar
le cauchemar de la salle bible le
cauchemar qui ne soit pas venu d'avoir
un cadeau près et personne pour le
recevoir
le cauchemar j'ai deux ans je viens
d'apprendre à marcher mes parents
détourne la tête
le cauchemar chez agnès varda on l'a
tous fait les réalisateurs les
réalisatrices le cauchemar d'être là par
exemple à un premier rendez vous
amoureux
et puis d'y rester selon temps avant de
vous amoureux ça va très vite on les
fonctions vite fait c'est se joua après
mais au cinéma au cinéma à partir de
combien on peut dire c'est un cauchemar
c'est un échec c'est raté à partir de
combien
aux etats unis c'est plus simple ça se
compte en dollars alors là évidemment
c'est moins personnel quoi ça nous
concerne moi directement mais en france
en france on des sentimentaux en france
on compte les spectateurs comme ça sur
les comptes à la main sur ma machine
mais normalement normalement il ya plus
que pour une main à partir de candidats
ils sont là ses formes y avait été un
succès à partir duquel chat millions 3
millions un million c'est incroyable
aurélia un million un million de
personnes
c'est quasiment battu quasiment
électorale quoi un million de personnes
sont déplacées ce inouï on peut le
croiser dans les villages dans les
campagnes sont là des quelques alertes
sympa heureux c'est mon spectateurs ce1
millions - cinq cent mille trois cent
mille 100 1000 c
bon c'est pas mal cent mille c'est plus
qu'on rentre comptera dans une vie quand
même 100 milles à tout le monde d'être
autant à 100000 sauf les financiers mais
ça comment rendre volet financier est ce
notre but dans la vie cent mille 90
mille dix mille 1000 milles spectateurs
pour mon film oui ce parent c'est pas
bennett comme on dit mille spectateurs
c'est quasiment des amis d'amis coire
n'était pas la peine de
professionnaliser son film 9 108 107 110
spectateurs
non quand même dix personnes
mais alors là ce qu'est ce qui est
bizarre c'est que dans ma famille rien
qu'avec les cousins du sud ouest on est
déjà 15
donc il ya des gens qui doivent donc
c'est la mauvaise communication
familiale on est pour rien là dix
personnes oui c'est difficile de se
réjouir
10 9 8 7 5 par personne
personne n'est venu c'est quasiment un
triomphe à l'envers quoi perche mais non
mais personne n'ose en personne personne
comme personne genre 0 quoi jean
personnes
on peut par compte et non 1 2 n'ont
vraiment pas même quelqu'un qui détient
il pleuvait je suis maintenant on va
leur personne
là c'est très difficile à une personne
c'est très physique non c'est pas si mal
c'est pas si mal j'aurais pu faire pire
non non objectivement je vois pas parce
que les chiffres négatifs n'existe pas
dans un trade salle mais c'est
miraculeux en fait que que les gens
viennent quand même dans les scènes de
cinéma non qui se déplacent parce que la
tentation la tentation d'être soi même
une fiction
avec les réseaux sociaux avec tout ce
qui vous soutient être soi même est soi
même un film est là est le laquais
follow la tentation de pu regarder de
plus concentré une minute trente c'est
beaucoup une vie série à 1h30 c'est quoi
être une fiction patino de fiction à des
petits fils des petits morceaux de films
nous-mêmes je suis un film alors de quel
côté de l'écran et le film au festival
de cannes
parfois la selle est tellement
spectaculaire que le film lui-même
s'arrêtent pour regarder c'est inouï
d'être là et pourtant existent encore
champeau règne ça existe à salles de
cinéma ce besoin d'être ensemble parce
que le cinéma ça n'est pas juste des
images des images meilleurs que d'autres
les images pure contre l'impur ça n'est
pas juste le grand écran contre le petit
le mais les yeux plutôt que les baisser
le cinéma le cinéma c'est la salle de
cinéma théâtre ensemble ouais c'est vrai
sortir de chez soi
ce miracle là plutôt que de rester là à
manger des pizzas au regard de netflix
ou bien regarder sa pizza ou bien je
regardais en train de regarder sa pizza
le cinéma c'est ça c'est le collectif
c'est le goût c'est la chaleur humaine
ne rentrez pas chez vous ce soir
bienvenue à la 72e cérémonie 72e
festival de cannes tout simplement merci
on la liane
[Applaudissements]